[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité yvelinoise
un nouveau site du département retenu
pour la sixième édition du Loto du
patrimoine il s'agit des cavenors du
parc du château de Maisons-Laffitte
construite au 17e siècle par
l'architecte François Mansart elles sont
dans un état de grande vétusté une
restauration a déjà été lancée l'an
passé l'objectif à terme y maintenir une
activité hippique et ouvrir le lieu au
public après les Restos du coeur c'est
au tour de la Croix-Rouge française de
tirer la sonnette d'alarme l'association
fait face à des difficultés financières
un déficit de 50 millions d'euros en
raison de la hausse des coûts et des
demandes d'aide plus 7% de demandes au
premier semestre de cette année dans les
Yvelines la Croix-Rouge dispose de 16
unités locales 11 épiceries sociales et
d'un camion itinérant qui sillonnent le
territoire à la rencontre des
bénéficiaires de son côté le
gouvernement indique avoir mobilisé 156
millions d'euros pour les alimentaires
cette année
l'hommage à Michel Hidalgo à
Clairefontaine ce matin le nouveau
complexe du nom de l'ancien
sélectionneur des Bleus décédés en 2020
a été inauguré au Centre national du
football pour l'occasion Didier
Deschamps sélectionneurs de l'équipe de
France Thierry Henry entraîneur des
espoirs et l'ex footballeur gentigana
était présent et aussi Valérie Pécresse
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France la
collectivité a soutenu ce projet à
hauteur d'un virgule 3 millions d'euros
pour la création de 40 chambres avec
vestiaire de différents espaces et de
deux terrains synthétiques